[Música]
hoy llegamos directo hasta el ecuador
donde el presidente de ese país
guillermo la zona seguro que la nación
enfrenta una guerra contra el
narcotráfico por lo que ofreció dotar de
mayor equipamiento y tecnología a la
policía y también las fuerzas armadas
especialmente en el área de inteligencia
saludamos entonces a nuestro
corresponsal en quito- gustavo ortega
gustavo muy buena mañana de miércoles
que podemos decir entonces del anuncio
del presidente guillermo lasso
una mañana para ti también efectivamente
el gobierno de ecuador específicamente
su presidente guillermo lasso ha
decretado declarado la guerra en contra
el narcotráfico y la criminalidad esto
lo hacía el día de ayer en medio de un
discurso en un acto castrense por la
posición de mando de el nuevo alto
militar esto sucede luego que se ha
cumplido inclusive un mes de declarar en
emergencia y en estado de sesión a tres
provincias del país son las tres
provincias más violentas debe tomar en
cuenta que en el año 2021
el ecuador incautó una cifra récord de
210 mil kilogramos de drogas para lo que
va de este año ya contabilizan
aproximadamente 90 mil según cifras
oficiales de la publicidad nacional debe
tomar en cuenta que el ejecutivo
nacional comienza su segundo año con una
fuerte crisis carcelaria donde el
objetivo nacional ha dicho que le ha
declarado la guerra al narcotráfico de
tomar en cuenta que se han producido por
lo menos seis distintas masacres
carcelarias esto sucede también cuando
el ejecutivo en nacional ha dicho que
1200 millones de dólares para dotar
principalmente la materia de
inteligencia en este sentido también ha
viajado a israel ha hecho acuerdo en
materia de inteligencia y entrenamientos
con los eeuu todo esto para poder
enfrentar los altos niveles de
criminalidad que también se sienten
ahora en la ciudad de las principales
ciudades del país raúl ahora ha gustado
también en otras noticias la presidenta
de la asamblea nacional fue destituida
agravando si así la crisis de
gobernabilidad entre el ejecutivo y el
parlamento que está sucediendo
tales como todas dicho esto podría
agravar la crisis de gobernabilidad hay
que tomar en cuenta que durante el
primer año de gobierno de el presidente
guillermo la sola característica ha sido
el bloqueo la crisis de gobernabilidad
entre el ejecutivo nacional y el
parlamento esto era un acto que
básicamente parecía inminente sucedió el
día de ayer básicamente los
parlamentarios destituyen por supuesta
incumplimiento de funciones a la primera
magistrada la primera coordinadora
presidenta de la asamblea nacional
guadalupe llori esto también ha emitido
el pronunciamiento por parte del
ejecutivo en nacional esto contradice
también el discurso del ejecutivo
nacional quien había dicho que respetaba
la independencia de las funciones del
gobierno nacional pero la madrugada de
ayer aproximadamente la una de la mañana
emitió un comunicado donde rechazaba
esta destitución de la presidenta de la
asamblea nacional esto
parece entrever que no quedará así ya
distintos sectores políticos han
expresado su preocupación y sobre todo
que se refleja cuáles han sido las
diferentes posiciones en contra del
ejecutivo nacional a favor de la ciudad
por parte de la asamblea nacional y el
gobierno a ciudades por el cual esta
crisis de gobernabilidad ha sido la
principal característica debe recordar
también que el presidente de la
república había amenazado con
anunciar la muerte cruzada una figura de
la constitución del ecuador que consiste
básicamente en la destitución de la
asamblea nacional y convocar así a
elecciones anticipadas por el cual luego
el ejecutivo nacional había negado que
iba a declarar esta figura
constitucional pero todo parece que
podría ser el inicio nuevamente de una
crisis de gobernabilidad entre el
parlamento y el ejecutivo nacional